è una cosa che ha catturato la vostra
attenzione fin da subito ma lo posso
capire anche per me è abbastanza strano
vedere un top che si in groppa un cane
da tutti ragazzi ovviamente nessuno
video sono fatti j
ed oggi un nuovo fantastico genuino blog
da vabbè allora vi spiego questa cosa
siccome tutti ma lo chiedo perché tanto
non passa inosservato sta cosa qua draga
suoli mi hanno messo il gesso il gesso
con la j volevo scrivere gesso j
processo j era una cantante un altro può
quindi con creativi hanno messo il gesso
ieri e lo dovrà ottenere per 15 giorni e
cause potrebbero essere tantissime cioè
nel senso potrei aver fatto a cazzotti
con un t rex potrei aver detto una donna
torna in cucina tuttavia verdetto a mia
nonna non ha più fame e non lo so una di
queste cose potrebbe essere la causa del
braccio niente di tutto questo ragazzi
perché la vera causa è che mi sono
chiuso il dito questo qui nella portiera
della macchina stava guardando il
telefono ho chiuso la portiera con la
mano e con la stessa mano mi è rimasto
incastrato sto dito poi io so tutto sto
popò di merda sul braccio solo perché
questo libro perché io con altre vita
sono libero nel senso potrei disegnare
potrei cucinare potrei farmi le severo
hanno dovuto fasciarmi tutto quanto
perché edito doveva restare fermo che
mai tra l'altro mi hanno ingessato tipo
come se fosse un like o mi piacerebbe
che poi vado in giro così chiariamo un
secondo mistero paghi come cazzo fai a
fare il gameplay adesso che c'è il gesso
e quindi ragazzi ora devo stare due
settimane senza fare video li prendevo
per il culo nave neanche tanto giocare
che mi riuscirà a difficile più che
altro anche il montare i video perché i
video li del mondo ovviamente io quindi
un macello ma nonostante questo ragazzo
ho deciso di continuare a fare video
tutti i giorni non mi va di lasciarvi
senza video o mio amico che si chiama
max hg molti di voi magari lo
conosceranno già che il ragazzo che non
ha le braccia e gioco dei videogames che
è una persona che io stimo e lui aveva
lanciato una star no excuses perché se
voi volete veramente fare qualcosa
mettendocela tutta non avete scuse per
non riuscire a farla quindi ragazzi non
permettete a voi stessi di auto
convincervi che non ci riuscirete perché
non è vero che ce lo ricorda anche il
nostro amico saia ovviamente fa chi è
quindi ragazzi non preoccupatevi perché
non sarà un [ __ ] gesto
impedirmi di fare video è stato così
stimolante quando mi hanno messo il
genero quasi contempo della serie cazzo
adesso voglio vedere se ce la faccio a
fare le cose così sono scemo ma è una
cosa che veramente mi ha dato più
stimolo che altro e questa è dedicato a
tutti i costi gli haters che speravano
che io smettessi ruhnke ragazzi il 18
dicembre vi toglieranno gesso quindi
tornerà ad essere tutto normale ma fino
ad allora vedete la come sei video games
che andrò a fare avessero giocato di
difficoltà in tv di ragazzi ciancio
levante passiamo al blog di oggi prima
di cominciare il primo è che ha
cominciato tipo mezz'ora fa ma
[ __ ] è affermata settimana è stata
vinta dall ice che ha fatto studi è
bellissimo è fottutamente bp che un arco
social a mano a posto riesca a fa sta
roba quindi complimento al ragazzo cerca
delle immagini mie in questi giorni ho
trovato qualcuno che vende la mia
immagine del red carpet a 500 euro ci
rende nemi magia 500 ed casse recon
prodigato capito che quando mi tolgo
adesso lo vendo su ebay a 2 milioni ma
ha detto queste ragazzine gli passerà lo
scarta già dei bachi che sarà veramente
un casino visto che voglio provarci però
sa che cosa esce fuori calami motta
ok ci siamo del parere o ragazzi abbiamo
il primo me lo vedo di fix mitchell
aprono le cose a cm e
nicchia che bestie segno se questo lo
faccio meglio ragazzi ce l'ho fatta
credo spero forze questa roba dei
gettoni per le giostre 9 grazie delle le
mie figurine ma perché le 10 euro del
monopoly porca [ __ ] quasi per
concludere delle manette che non posso
mettermi neanche volendo ma perché
voglio fare delle cose sporche non mi
possono mettere le manette non ci stanno
ciò vuol dire che posso commettere
crimini ragazzi non possono arrestare
che filtro domani ammazzo qualcuno già
minato lo squartatore ga prosciutti ce
lo fa abbiamo un spero ti piaccia ma non
ha funzionato un po la prevenzione
protegge la tua salute perché tu pensi
che io lo faccia senza i preservativi
allora voglio vedere chemical e se fuori
casta roba perché è una scatolina ma no
ma no
ma cosa sono perché ci sono delle cose e
poi c'è questo che sono io anche il
braccio ingessato bellissimo e
realistico 10 su 10 è veramente quello
che penso e non riesco aprirlo no
scherzavo
veramente no ma dai lega ma me ne vado
di casa mamma non è mio questo mio non è
mio nemico non è milano non è mio
ragazzi ho creato un arma di distruzione
di massa senza volerlo ma qui il fallout
borea e lasciamo perdere
direi che possiamo passare a farli
risponde prima che la cosa si complichi
ma si sa la fame riscalda la prima
lavando arriva da manuele che mi chiede
fa v.no favino farinoso inventato
problema è portato a cucinare qualcosa
alla fine ti sta riferendo al fatto che
la volta scorsa ho fatto vedere video
che ho bruciato la cucina perché mi
stavo facendo un tetro come se non
bastasse sta settimana ho aumentato
ancora un po di più la difficoltà
sto per morire l'ha fatto morire il
figlio dove balli con i tuoi amici o
invitate gli amici a casa sono stati due
giorni a casa mia e siamo andati poi in
giro a far festa robe del genere ha
fatto un video dove tipo dovevamo andare
in discoteca la sera media avevano tutti
un sonno della madonna destro il video
questa sera facciamo grande festa e
siamo carichi
[Musica]
la ciliegina sulla torta è statro finale
ragazza mia mi scrive farli fa è nato
speciale in realtà è da un pezzo che non
ne faccio ma ho deciso di far uscire
speciali a caso scusatemi se non
risponde alle altre domande altra roba
però devo andare a montare il titolo
perché sono annuncia faccio a far uscire
in tempo essere bene siamo abbastanza
pesante sui giorni messo così però vabbè
si può fare guai se ce la faccio mi
batte il cinque
quindi ragazzi prima di concludere di
ripassare la fai domanda di oggi
l'affare non andrà di oggi e consigliate
di un gioco anche di quelli che ho già
fatti posso farmi qualche mario che è
cristo nero nel fare col braccio
ingessato perchè un gioco che sia
difficile da fare con due mani che teme
la richiesta che vi sta facendo
mivogliobene padre lo sapere qui sotto
nei commenti così almeno ci sarà del
masochismo puro creed ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto ma solido lasciate un
commento è un mi piace
bressi avanti voglio onlit di youtube è
cambiato con questo è anche la pagina di
facebook e come ogni video trovate nella
descrizione susseguirsi di sky tree ci
vediamo al prossimo video beh ragazzi